you brought a video clip to promote you
were just discussing this this show that
you do 79 now ' it's a comedy show that
my husband and I have toured and we're
making a special for epics we're
shooting at January 14th and Irvine if
you'd like to come you're formally
invited firstly invited you brought a
clip I'm told to help promote the show
is that right yeah this is just a random
this is just around the house just real
documentary footage of you and how you
and your husband Nick Offerman interact
let's take a look it's my husband go for
Megan hey hey what are you wearing
titties thank you yeah girl
it's only five or six times a day it's
not that bad
[Applause]
actually took quite a lot longer than
usual and Karina get worried
you